all right welcome everybody welcome to
my session about blazer hopefully
everybody's had a good conference so far
my name is ed Charbonneau I'm a
developer advocate for progress I work
on the telluric products for progress
I'm an author and I'm frequently on
Twitter if you guys have any questions
later feel free to hit me on twitter by
my name so welcome to goodbye javascript
hello blazer so we're going to talk
about blazer today a new framework from
Microsoft that lets us build spa
applications using dotnet now what if I
told you we could write client-side web
applications using only c-sharp too many
dotnet developers like myself this
sounds like something that we've always
wanted and we've actually tried this
before some of those things worked out
well some may not web forms in my
opinion was really successful there's a
lot of web forms applications that are
still out there they're still being
built and maintained Silverlight however
had a little bit of an early demise so
it's not around and supported anymore
so it's probably time to to move away
from Silverlight but you'll see that
blazars something that we can migrate to
from these technologies so blazer is a
brand new framework it gets its name
from the razor engine so it's the
browser plus blazer is a browser plus
razor is blazer and this allows us to
run c-sharp and HTML in the browser and
I'm going to show you how that the.net
team accomplished that in just a minute
so just some of the facts about blazer
what it is and what it is not so first
of all it is client-side c-sharp we're
actually going to be running c-sharp on
the client it uses web standard
technologies so there's no plugins like
Silverlight hat so we're we're gonna use
web standards and things that already
exist in the clients browser we're not
gonna have to make them install anything
else and it does that through web
assembly so web assembly is the
technology that's built into the browser
that's gonna allow this to happen
and what's nice is we can use net
standard so anything that's a dotnet
standard library in general should run
inside a blazer so again it's not a
plugin there's no nothing for the client
to install it's not web forms all over
again
there are some similarities here and
there because it is dotnet so there's
gonna be things that look familiar and
there's no transporation c-sharp codes
not being turned into JavaScript
in fact our c-sharp code isn't being
turned into webassembly either and I'll
explain how that works in just a second
so the key difference is for me are that
blazer enables me as a.net developer to
use the tools and the languages that I'm
familiar with so I can be more
productive so there's nothing really
wrong with JavaScript and the takeaway
from this talk isn't really to bash
javascript or say that we shouldn't use
it anymore but I wanted to share some of
the strengths that I find with blazer
and that is that I can use dotnet
standard libraries so things that I've
already written in c-sharp things that
existed before blazer I can use and I
have some examples of that I can share
I'm using the MS build pipeline so I'm
using the build engine that I'm used to
using I'm not going off and using
webpack or something that is completely
foreign to the development stack that
I'm used to and of course c-sharp that's
strong typed language that I enjoy
working in works inside a blazer and I
don't need to switch between JavaScript
and C sharp when I'm working front end
and back end so these are some of the
things that make Blazer really
productive for me so I don't have to use
those JavaScript technologies that I'm
not familiar with like NPM web pack and
typescript so I talked a little bit
about web assembly let's clear up
exactly what web assembly is because
that's how blazer on the client side is
being enabled so web estate web assembly
is a web standard format and it's
assembly like language that allows the
web page to execute code and this is
what makes blazer possible now blazer is
this fully functional single page or
application framework that has
everything from dependency injection to
robust component model everything that
you need to build a spa application and
it even has component packages which is
what my company focuses on we build
components for every ecosystem on the
web and blazars one of those things that
we build these UI components for so
Blaser has two models of operation it
has a server and a client-side model so
we'll talk about both of these I'm going
to talk a little bit more in detail on
the client-side model because that seems
to be something that people are really
focused on when they talk about Blaser
and something that people are really
excited about so let's talk about how
the client-side actually works in a
normal browser application or JavaScript
application we download our JavaScript
to the browser that JavaScript gets
parsed it gets compiled and turned into
an abstract syntax tree it gets then
turned into byte code that byte code
then interacts with the Dom calling Dom
api's and those things web assembly
opens up a new interface for us so
instead of going through that javascript
pipeline and having the browser parse
and compile our javascript inside of the
browser itself we're actually opening up
a new interface here where we can put
byte code directly into the browser
through web assembly so web assemblies
what's enabling this new technology that
you're gonna see so what Microsoft has
done is they've taken well first of all
web assembly does open up the ecosystem
as well so you see here we can use
things like C++ and C sharp and compile
those things outside of the browser
instead of having to go through that
JavaScript pipeline so this this opens
things up and this is what allows
Microsoft to do what they're doing and
that is compile the dotnet runtime to
web assembly and run that directly in
the browser so this means I don't have
to
compiled my code to another language I
don't have to transpile from something
to JavaScript I just need the run net
code in the browser in the.net runtime
just like a normal net application so we
have the dotnet runtime in the browser
and blazer is loaded up on top of that
and then our application code gets
loaded into the browser as well so we're
actually shipping dll's down the wire to
the browser and running them on the
client server side blazer is a very
interesting option this is really nice
for line of business applications and
how server side blazer works is we're
actually running all the application
code on the server and we're treating
the the browser's a thin client so
there's a small JavaScript file that
gets delivered to the browser and that
sets up a signal our connection between
the server and the browser so now we
have a thin client that we can work with
that thin client is responsible for Dom
updates and those type of things and
whenever there's an event on the client
it sends a message up to the server
using signal our performs any work and
then sends down just a difference
between what the UI is and what it
should be
so we're if we change like an h1 tag
that's the only thing that's gonna come
across the wire we're not repainting the
whole page and that actually goes across
as binary so it's a very small packet of
information and then the client-side
thin-client
part of the framework picks up and
replaces that element for us so it's a
very lightweight very responsive way of
building applications and there's a
couple trade-offs between these two
models so on the client side we have
little to no server overhead we can host
these things on github pages there's
static files it's again it's a typical
web scenario so it's a restful type of
application meaning that we have web a
Web API s we're interacting with for
data on the server so we're in a
disconnected environment this allows
also things like offline mode and
lwas to be built with blazer client-side
which is very interesting prospect the
downsides are the larger payload side
size so we're shipping the.net framework
across the wire which can be a little
bit on the large side something that the
dotnet team is currently working on
it's a disconnected environment so we
have to make API calls to get data from
our server it is not supported by
Microsoft yet so support is actually
coming in May so I'd look around the
build time frame for the official RTM
version of client-side blazer so you can
use it today in preview but there's no
support yet server-side blazer has very
small payload size because it's only
shipping that small client package
across that little signal our service
that it has what's nice though it has a
lot less abstraction because they're
already on the server we may actually be
on the same server with our database we
can inject entity framework directly
into the application and use it without
writing a whole abstraction layer of
using web api calls
so this uptime on getting a server-side
application is the development time is
very very short
it also has pre rendering enabled on the
box it's extremely fast it's supported
today so Microsoft has already released
support for this several months ago and
that happened during dotnet comp
so since net kampf this has been
officially supported by Microsoft in asp
net 3.0 downside is you have to have a
connection all the time that web socket
has to be able to communicate to the
server so that's something to keep in
mind and resources are on your dime so
if you have a big as your instance
that's running all of the code then
obviously you're paying for any kind of
computation that happens there the
client-side you're not going to have
that one thing that I really like about
blazer is that it has a very simple
component model that is extremely
scalable and you can sum it all up in
this one slide so
a component is made up of directives
which give a component special abilities
like page routing which you can see in
this example there they also contain
markup this is just standard HTML markup
that can include razor and other
components so it's very easy to to use
because it's just HTML and then we have
our code block or our logic for that
component we can put these in the same
view we could separate those code files
out as well but generally if it's
something simple you'll see it like this
where we have the code right in the
component itself
and you can see data binding is very
simple I'll show some live demos of this
as well but we simply use razor to
connect our our data to the display and
we combine two click events and this is
all c-sharp there's no JavaScript here
routing is very simple routing uses a
directive so we can set up a page
directive we can even pass in query
string variables and accept those into
our component very easily using this
syntax so in this example where we're
taking in a parameter and displaying
that up on the page and that's that's
how you would set that up with the
routing and Blaser dependency injection
comes baked into the framework as well
so we can inject things like HTTP client
if you've written any dotnet code that's
done HTTP work before you'll see that
this is very familiar we're injecting an
HTTP client and then calling get Jason
async to grab some data so I'll show
I'll show some demos of that here and
we'll go ahead and and do that just in a
second so we'll get started just to let
you know what the prereq prerequisites
are if you want to try this out if
you're gonna do any client-side Blaser
you're gonna want to grab the latest
version of.net core so right now it's
3.1 preview 2 is what just released two
days ago so this is very bleeding edge
stuff I'm about to show so if anything
goes wrong it's not my fault I promise
we need Visual Studio 2019 latest
preview which shipped I believe
yesterday
it was updating on my machine just about
an hour ago
so again if something breaks I have
other people to blame we're gonna do
some final new project stuff you'll see
there's two different projects in the
file new project dialog we have our
blazer webassembly project which is the
client-side model and the blazer server
project which is the server-side model
so it's demo time let's break away from
the slides for a few minutes and take a
look at Blazer and see how it works so
again I'm opening Visual Studio which
you can't see let's change presentation
modes here so if we can get that up on
the screen properly so we have Visual
Studio 2019 preview and I'm gonna do
create a new project and I'll be
choosing blazer app and you'll notice
that I get a dialog box that has two
projects in it I'd noticed little bug
earlier so if you see this happen you
only have one project you need to
install those Blazer webassembly app
templates and then sometimes toggling
the version of asp net core you have
will light those up as well because
we're on preview 3.1 preview so we're
only gonna find that web app web
assembly app in that 33.1 dialog so go
ahead and create this web assembly
application again this is going to be
all static resources so this is an
application that we don't need a server
to host we could put this on github
pages or Azure blob storage or something
like that and it would run perfectly
fine which is something that's new for
dotnet we haven't been able to do web
applications without some sort of server
or is for for our apps in our file new
project experience we'll see the
directory structure is pretty simple
that it's not MVC so there's no Model
View controller it's very similar to
Razer pages if you've done any Frazer
pages so you'll notice there's a pages
folder and
shared folder will find all of our
components under pages here all of our
static resources like JavaScript if we
have any or CSS will be under w w root
images things like that so we'll jump
into pages here we've got a couple
simple application examples in here we
go ahead and run this before we start
digging into the code so we'll give this
a little build and let this run and
we're gonna see there's two examples
there's a counter component and a fetch
data component there's also an index
page and we'll have a little fun with
this for a few minutes and see what
exactly the component model gives us and
the final new project experience gives
us here so we've got a counter component
it's a very simple example but it does a
lot for us and we can play with this a
little bit so if we click the button it
counts the increment increments the
count up and we also have a fetch data
so we can click on fetch data and it
will pull data from in this case a
static file it's actually grabbing a
JSON file and parsing that out for us so
let's take a look at the code and this
is the counter component so you'll
notice that the counter component has a
page directive so it has a route so
we're able to navigate to this component
and it acts as a page when we give a
page a route or a component or route
it's still a component we can still use
it as a component now components and
Blaser are very reusable we can put
those on other pages so for example I
could go to my index page and I could
create a new instance of that counter
component just by coming in and saying
counter and closing that tag so that is
a reuse of our counter component it's
very simple so now I have two instances
of my counter component so I have a
counter component I can navigate to now
I have one on my index page as well and
those are both separate instances of
that component the component itself is
just made up of some simple markup we
have an h1 tag that's our
we have our current count being
displayed with a little bit of razor
syntax here so we're displaying the
current count field of our our class
that we have and we're also binding to
an on-click event so we're gonna bind to
the increment count method you can see
light up here in the code section this
is all c-sharp
I'll see sharp code there's no
JavaScript here at all so I'm gonna save
this index page and we'll we'll light
this up again we'll go back to the
browser and see that we have these two
separate instances of our counter
component so we should have one on our
index page now where we didn't have it
before so I can click that increments I
go to my counter route I have another
instance again it's at 0 so we're we're
not sharing any state there or anything
like that so now we have these two
counter components let's let's see how
we can expand this component model a
little bit because we need to be able to
give values to components right so we're
gonna go over to our code section and
let's expand this counter component so
it can be we can enable it to count by
different values so let's add a
parameter to it and I'm gonna add I'm
gonna use a little code snippet to kind
of shorten this up a little bit but what
we have is a basic class property and
it's been decorated with a parameter
attribute so that tells Blaser that this
is an input for our component and we'll
go ahead and set this as an integer and
we'll call it count by and I'm gonna go
ahead and just default this to 1 in case
somebody doesn't set a value for it it
doesn't do nothing and now we just need
to change our logic a little bit because
we were just incrementing by 1 so what
we want to do is actually increment by
count by so now when I have a component
I can set this count by value and we can
count by a different set of numbers so I
can go back to my counter component and
I can say count by and already
intellisense is lit up with that
parameter so I can set it and it
also knows that it's an integer value so
I'm gonna say five so now my counter on
my home page will count as five and my
counter that is that the counter route
will still be one so it's very easy to
create components and pass values in and
make them change their behavior so this
this component model is very easy to
work with you can see I'm counting by
5's now may be a little hard to see in
the back there but we're we're counting
by five on the home page and we're
counting by ones on the counter out
I switched tabs by accident there so
there we go
so we've got fives and ones we've also
got our our fetch data component let's
talk about that for a minute because
it's doing something a little bit
different so the fetch data component is
actually utilizing dependency injection
so we've got our inject method up here
or directive at the top and this tells
dependency injection to go ahead and
resolve a HTTP client instance for us
and it's going to pull that out of the
dependency injection system that's baked
in and in our code section we're gonna
call get Jason async and we're actually
just gonna fetch a flat file here we're
gonna go grab whether jason but for all
intents and purposes this could be an
HTTP call to anywhere it could be a
github API it could be anything and
we're gonna pull data back as a see a
c-sharp class so weather forecast
class is coming back an array of weather
forecasts so we're the framework is
actually doing all of the parsing and
serialization and deserialization
between jason for us so we don't even
have to worry about that we're gonna
await that function and set our forecast
field once we have that we'll iterate
over that field and display those table
columns so it's pretty straightforward
stuff here
let's go ahead and do another file new
project because I want to show the
difference between client side and
server side blazer and you can really
see that difference in the the fetch
data component that they give you as
part of the example so I'm going to go
to the server side app here I'm going to
click create and we're going to get an
identical experience here except for a
folder called data so before we didn't
have this data folder and this is going
to tie in to our weather forecast
component that where we're working with
oh come on my zoom has broken my little
zoom tool I was going to zoom in on this
for you this is weather forecast dots
yes for the folks in the back and
weather forecast service which is a
service that will fetch some random
weather data for us it's just doing this
through random on random number
generator but this could be database for
example it could be entity framework
sitting back here pulling data out for
us I'm gonna go into pages and back over
to fetch data and we have almost the
same setup here except the inject
directive is different in a server-side
blazer we're on the server already so we
can inject services that exist on the
server and we can inject an ad framework
even directly into this component and
utilize it because we don't have that
HTTP call that we have to make to get
the data so I'm gonna inject a weather
forecast service and we resolve it
almost the exact same way here but I'm
gonna call service get forecast async
now what get forecast async does behind
the scenes we really don't even need to
need to care about but we know it's
going to return a array of weather
forecasts and then we can then iterate
over it so you'll see there's a little
bit of difference in how we call
services and get data between server
side and client side blazer but the
component itself the markup section the
routing and all of that remains
unchanged this is all the same logic
across
either server side or client side blazer
what's nice about this is that I can
write my services where they abstract
away how it's getting the data and then
I don't even need to worry about how my
components are written whether they'll
work on client or server side blazer I
can make them completely agnostic it's
where they can run anywhere so let's
give this a run we'll take a look at the
two applications running and I'll show
some other differences between the two
models so this is the same counter
application I didn't put the custom
counter implementation here but we have
our basic hello world app with our fetch
data and our counter component it's a
little bit hard to see in such a simple
scenario but the client side app is much
much faster so the server side app is
much much quicker than the client side
application it looks like I may have
closed my server our client app so we'll
get that back of it running I want to
show the two side-by-side there are some
key differences at how they're they're
operating while that loads up we will
take our server side application here
I'm gonna do inspect and I'll grab the
network tab and I'm gonna empty the
cache here and just completely reload
the application and we'll see the
resources that come across the wire so
we've got less than a half a mega data
that's been transferred over this is a
lot of you know static files like CSS
files there's a small JavaScript file in
here that boots up the the client-side
application of this it establishes the
signal our connection so this is
actually the signal our connection here
and you can see these binary messages
that are in the queue will scoot this
screen over a little bit and if I click
on my counter you'll see the binary
messages being sent across the wire so
it may be a little hard to see I'll give
it a couple more clicks you can see the
scrollbar
kind of bouncing over here those are the
signal our packages going up to the
server saying I clicked a button what
happened and then the server says
changed the 1 to a 2 the 2 to a 3 and so
on if we go back to our client side app
we'll give this a run we're gonna see a
different set of information come across
the network and this is where we can
really see how client and server-side
Blaser are different so here's our
client-side application again where do
you inspect here and we will empty the
cache on that guy and reload the page
take a look at our network tab it's a
little bit more busy so I see some
grimacing faces
yes that's 2.4 Meg's that went over the
wire so again we are shipping the dotnet
framework and dll's over the wire so
it's a little bit heavy right now so
this is why Microsoft has extended the
the support date out to 2 May is because
they're still working on trimming this
down and making it a little bit more
efficient sending that data across the
wire so there's something in Blazer that
we use called the il linker and if
you're familiar with tree-shaking a
javascript it's a very similar concept
so what we're gonna do is look through
the code and see what paths the code is
using so what methods it's calling and
that il linker will then shake out
anything that's not being used and
reduce the size of those dll files down
and make this a little bit more
palatable to send to clients so there's
some there's some performance tweaks
that are happening right now that
hopefully we see by May that'll make
this a little bit better we are seeing
dll's shipping across the wire so these
are dll's that are actually running in
the application on the client so this is
pretty cool stuff one thing that's
interesting about this is people ask
about security a lot when they see this
there's a couple
discussions to be had one is Ken Ken
clients decompile the code and look at
the code well of course they can it's on
their machine we can do this with
JavaScript today so it's not anything
different than what we're already doing
so we can take JavaScript that's been
sent across the wire look at the code
it's a little bit more of an extra step
to decompile c-sharp but it is possible
matter-of-fact telluric the company I
work for has a free tool too did the
compiled code so there's something
that's possible if you have something
that's that's got a sensitivity just
keep it on the server as a service and
call it as an API so that it's it's a
really simple problem to fix
now these DLL is run in a sandbox the
same sandbox that JavaScript runs in so
we're not gaining any special access
just because it's DLL files and dotnet
code so we can't do things like go
figure out who's logged in with active
directory so we don't get any magic for
free just because it's not net which
also means we can't do destructive
things like go get the person's registry
and mess with it and install viruses and
those type of things okay so there
there's a lot of security questions that
people ask those are generally the ones
that I get one thing that I really enjoy
about Blaser is the fact that we can use
existing dotnet code to build
applications this is an experiment that
I did when blazer very first came out
this is called blaze down there's
actually a live version of this on the
web as well we can actually try to hit
that real quick
so what blaze down is is an application
that you know I saw a blazer and I
thought what does the web need more than
anything and that is another online
markdown editor that's a joke come on we
don't need that I'm sorry we don't but I
thought it was a good experiment so I
was like let's build an online mark down
editor
that uses dotnet and I don't know
anything about parsing markdown not a
thing still don't built the app still
don't but what I was able to do is go to
nougat and grab a nougat package that
can parse markdown into HTML and it was
very simple to wire that up into two
little views and then you can go in and
edit your markdown and it will display
in the other window so it's doing some
live markdown parsing there's no server
for this it's hosted on github pages so
that's something that's really cool you
can actually import files directly into
it and you can also download and export
files it's a couple lines of code it's
really simple to write so that was
pretty interesting what I've been
working on lately is a project for our
company so we build UI components and I
feel like the best way to make these
things the best they can be for
customers is to use them myself so I've
been writing some application code to
not only test out Blaser but test out
our own UI components and see what I can
build so this is an application I wrote
called blaze port it's a futuristic
travel app so we're gonna travel to
other planets and we're gonna get prices
of travel too from the earth to the moon
to Mars and what we've got with blaze
port is a full stack c-sharp application
this is running server-side Blaser it's
running machine learning so ml net it
uses cosmos DB and sequel light for data
persistence I can click on new trip this
is our one of our UI components we have
this nice flyout effect for a panel we
have dropdowns and date pickers and all
the things that you need to build a
robust web application right here we can
estimate the trip cost it's going to go
out to the machine learning service and
ask it all right we have a distance and
we have a date and we have these
different inputs can you estimate the
cost that it's going to take to travel
to the moon and it's going to say yeah
you have four thousand nine hundred and
eight dollar ticket
this is how long it's gonna take and
this is the the number of miles you're
going to travel so it's kind of a cool
little demo app that that I wrote all
using Blaser and there is little to no
JavaScript that I've had to write for
this there's one little piece of
JavaScript I'm currently implementing
and something I didn't get a chance to
talk about yet is we have the ability to
call existing JavaScript libraries
through Blaser and utilize those
libraries so we have full access to
JavaScript and JavaScript also has full
access to c-sharp and net inside of
blazer so one of the things that I'm
working on with this example application
so I wanted it to have adaptive
rendering technology so what that means
is if I'm on a mobile device and my
screen size shrinks down not only can I
do media queries and change the layout
of the page and whatnot but I could
actually swap out entire user interfaces
based on what that screen size is so I'm
using a little snippet of JavaScript
code behind the scenes to detect the
browser size and tell me how big or
small it is and I use that for this
flyout panel to resize it appropriately
to fit the mobile screen so you'll
notice when I expand this out it changes
and instantly in size so there's a
little JavaScript call in there to say
all right we need to go change this UI
out a little bit so there's little
things that we can do like that we can
also implement full JavaScript libraries
people have used like Google Maps and
things like that so all those
capabilities are there with Blaser I
think I'm running short on time here may
actually be going a little bit over so
I'm gonna go ahead and put resources up
here so if anybody wants to snap a photo
of this there's some good links in here
we've got a lot of stuff going on on our
blogs and my website I do a twitch live
show every week on Friday if I'm not
traveling and you can see me live code
and fail at writing Blaser and I also
have an article in code magazine this
month so if your code magazine
subscriber or you can read it online he
and you can follow me on twitter and ask
questions if you like so thank you very
much enjoy your lunch
[Applause]